ROBERTO PEON: Hello, my
name is Roberto Peon.
I'm one of the co-inventors
for SPDY, welcome.
If you are here to hear about
SPDY, well, you are in the
right place because it's here.
So what we're going
to talk about.
We're going to talk
about the past.
We're going to talk about what
the world looks like today.
What is speedy, how to optimize
for it, where we're
going in the future.
And then we'll talk about stuff
that's either supporting
it already or that you can
use to get it working.
And then I'll go over an example
of adding ServerPush.
So the past, in the beginning
the speed of light was C. OK,
well let's try again.
That was a little bit too far.
So in the beginning of the
web, we had HTTP 0.9.
Well, that's what
we call it now.
It didn't have a name there.
In 1991 it was defined.
And basically HTTP 0.9 was a
request, get HTML protocol.
There was no images,
no anything else.
And very soon after, in
1996, we got HTP 1.0.
And it brought in headers,
including unresponses, and
servers could reply
with errors.
And clients could now upload
data, not just in the URL, but
with posts.
And they could indicate that
resources we're going to be
cast, and lots of other
good features.
Shortly thereafter, 1997-1999,
so basically they got to work
on it immediately,
we got HTTP 1.1.
And HTTP 1.1 gave us persistent
connections, which is great.
It also gave us trunk transfers,
which allows us to
send responses that don't
necessarily have there size
pre-computed before we've
begun the response.
So in 1999 pages were
very different.
Specifically, they were tiny.
They were around
60k on average.
And at that time, it was
probably good enough.
And I'll show you what Google
looked like in 1999.
Here it is.
Google, this page here, was
between the 13k compressed and
14k uncompressed.
It was tiny.
OK, so what does it
look like today?
In 2012, here you go.
This page is around 200k
compressed, and with
uncompressed, it's
around 600k.
This is a big difference
from 14k.
So today, pages are
a lot bigger.
And they're composed of
more resources, using
a bunch more domains.
And I'll get into exactly how
many on average soon.
And they're far more dynamic.
And, because of something
that's about to come up,
security is a much bigger
concern than it was.
And, of course, today the speed
of light is still C. It
hasn't changed.
And that means that RTTs are
not going to be going down,
because of course we haven't
made the speed
of light any faster.
And the speed of light
actually bounds RTT.
So here let's look
at the effective
bandwidth as RTT decreases.
You'll notice that the bandwidth
goes up quite a bit
more as we decrease RTT than
if we just simply add
bandwidth to our
communications.
So on the right hand side
here, we see effective
bandwidth of HTTP if we
add more speed to
the connection, right?
We're widening the pipe.
And basically it looks like we
kind of top out at around 1.6
megabytes a second here.
Whereas if we look on the other
side, we achieve that by
decreasing latency to around
50 milliseconds or so.
So RTT actually ends
up mattering a lot.
In 2010, which was about a year
after we started doing
all this, a web page was about
702k on average, used about 74
individual resources.
And it talked to about
10 different domains.
And today bigger,
more, more, OK?
And now, as compared to 1999,
as compared to 2010, the
stakes are higher.
More people depend on it.
And, more specifically, because
of this, you probably
depend upon it.
So SPDY, it's here.
What is it?
I've heard this question a
number of times today as I was
talking to random people.
It's a session-layer replacement
for HTTP.
And, well, so, why?
HTTP, I mean, it's been
here for a while.
It's been here since 1999 in
it's current incarnation.
Why do we care?
Well, you should care because
the idea is that it's going to
make it faster.
It's going to make
it more secure.
And it should be doing it with
less effort on your part.
So I've spent some time trying
to do some webpage page
organization.
It's pretty hard, You have to
keep a lot in your head.
And you have to know a lot about
who your customers are,
where they are, how far away
from you, what their links are
like, what they're packet loss
is like, how the particular
set of browsers that they're
using are going to interpret
the resources when you get it.
It's a big, really difficult
problem.
I'm hoping that we can make
some of this easier.
And, as a result, make webpages
faster, because we
should be doing things that make
it faster for you when
you do it the way that you
think is most forthright.
We shouldn't be making it so
you have to do all this
complex stuff in order to get a
page that is performing for
your users.
But no guarantees.
So how does it work?
So first of all, it's
always over TLS.
So you can have HTTPS
schemes in your URLs
and it can be SPDY.
You can have HTTP schemes
in your URLs.
It can still be SPDY, although
we don't do the same
certificate checks for
those resources.
It's still going to be better
than HTTP because you're at
least going to get point
to point privacy.
So if you're in a web cafe and
somebody is sniffing, you
never know, right?
If you're using SPDY, and that
HTTP resource is going over
SPDY, then that person doing the
sniffing isn't going to be
able to catch it.
That, I think, is pretty cool.
That's not the only
reason though.
Has anyone experienced this?
Transparent proxies get in
your way all the time.
You think, you know what, I've
deployed my own application.
Let's say on an Android phone.
It does some HTML.
I control it.
Got the server, control
that too.
Surprise, compression
doesn't work.
Surprise, other things happen.
OK, well the truth of the matter
is, on port 80, despite
the fact that you think you
own both sides of the
connection, transparent
proxies are in there.
They're mucking with it.
They're changing stuff.
This basically makes it really
hard to deploy anything new,
whether or not it's part of the
HTTP/1.1 spec on port 80.
And actually, just so you know,
it makes it really hard
to deploy HTTP/1.1 on port 80
because the subset of HTTP
that people actually speak
on port 80, it's
not the full subset.
So, another fun bit, firewalls,
great security,
great for keeping the stuff
you don't want out.
But, of course, you have to
know you don't want it.
So most firewalls end up,
they're open on port 80 and
443 by default.
And that's the world
as it exists.
So, as I mentioned before, if
you're always over TLS,
doesn't matter what the scheme,
then all the various
requests that you make will have
that kind of security.
SPDY does header compression.
So if you've ever looked at the
HTTP request stream, for
instance you've brought up the
Dev tools in Chrome, you will
see a lot of headers.
And it's a lot of text.
And it's text.
And you will see that most of
the stuff is repeated over,
and over, and over, again
for every request.
As an example, your user agent,
yeah, you know, I've
noticed that my user agent
doesn't change terribly often
over the lifetime of a
connection for my browser.
No, not really, except
encoding,
pretty much the same.
All of these other things
don't change.
The version of the connection.
It generally doesn't change.
At least over SPDY you're
guaranteed it's a full end to
end connection.
So it's not going to change.
All this stuff means that
we're sending a lot of
information over and over again
that we really don't
have to do.
So, as I said, much of the
headers are repeated.
I mentioned user agent.
Thought about the cookie yet?
How big is that cookie
you send on every
request, every time?
They're pretty big.
At least they can be.
I've seen cookies in
excess of 32k.
It's really cool when that ends
up being represented by
one byte, much faster.
HTTP methods, most
of them are get.
Some of them are posts.
Yeah, I don't know why we just
keep using all those
characters for that
every time.
And, of course, the HTTP version
string, mentioned
that, right?
Slash r, slash ns at the
end of every line?
Every line, two bytes, why?
And there's more.
So how effective is it?
Well on the first request on
the left hand side of this
graph, we see it's somewhere
between 10 and 40% on the
first request.
That's pretty good.
On subsequent requests on the
same connection, you can get
much better.
For instance, looking at this,
we see generally between 80
and 99% of compression with
a big spike around 97%.
I think that's pretty good
because I think that most of
the stuff that's in the headers
isn't actually useful
most of the time.
So we shouldn't be
penalized for it.
So mobile, I've noticed a lot of
excitement over at Android.
Got one in my pocket,
I like it too.
But I've also notice that the
net connection, despite all
the promises I've
been getting, is
really not that fast.
And it seems to be a lot faster
in the upload direction.
Wait, OK, it's slower in
the upload direction.
This actually really matters for
requests because most of
what you're sending isn't going
to be a big upload from
a mobile phone.
Sometimes it is.
Sometimes you've taken a
wonderful video of your
daughter or something
like that.
And you're going to upload it.
In which case, you probably
don't care about latency.
But if you're doing web stuff,
you're sending requests.
And generally, there's
not a big post
body attached to them.
So the headers end up
being most of it.
And when you're opening up your
connection, because of
the way TCP works, it's going
to throttle you down.
And it's going to throttle
you down early.
And it's going to
learn over time.
And it's going to open up that
window slowly, so that we
don't cause congestion and
a cascade failure of the
internet, which would be bad.
So it's probably a good idea
But if we put more relevant
information in the upload
direction, we're more likely
to get responses in the downward
direction by the
server sooner.
So that's the basic idea.
It's Binary Framed.
Now, if you're writing
a web app this
isn't going to matter.
But if you're deciding that
you're going to modify your
server or your client to speak
SPDY it's a lot easier to
write a binary protocol than
it is to parse HTTP.
And, having written a few HTTP
parsers, it's a lot easier.
OK
So it's also faster to parse.
It's a nice benefit.
It's not a huge field.
HTTP parsing shouldn't be taking
up any major amount of
time, even if you're doing it
in interpretive language.
It's the complexity of writing
it that's the hard bit.
It's multiplexed.
It's multiplexed to the tune of,
let's say, we can support
around a billion on one
TCP connection.
Now, I've mentioned the
average before.
The average is around 80
something, 84 I think it was,
requests per page.
So we have some runway.
And if we decide in the future
that we don't have enough, one
billion is not enough, we can
add another opp code, define
another frame type,
and there we go.
And the way to protocol is
specced out, that should
basically be backwards
compatible because we'll be
able to figure out whether
or not that
will work in the handshake.
And we can reject individual
frames if we have to.
Unlike HTTP, SPDY is full
duplex bi-directional.
So any stream can be sending and
receiving simultaneously.
This will make things like
layering web sockets over, if
we ever actually get to
it, really easy to do.
And this will allow us to use
the one TCP connection for all
of these things.
So we're trying to plan not
just for HTTP, although we
think that we can get a lot
of benefit for HTTP.
But we're also trying to plan
for other things in the future
that will allow us to do more
interesting things for you.
Prioritization, I don't
know how intently
you've looked at things.
But you've probably done it.
And you've probably been curious
because you see the
request go out, you see the
response come back, and then
there's this period
of time where
nothing appears to happen.
The browser isn't sending
any requests.
Well, what's happening there
is the browser is actually
doing something that's really
smart for you for HTTP.
It's looking at it, and it says,
aha, I haven't quite
finished receiving that CSS or
JavaScript that you requested
as part of a page.
I'm not going to request these
images yet, because in HTTP if
you're connected to 10 different
domains, maybe you
have 12, let's say.
Maybe you have 70 some
odd connections.
There's no way of throttling the
server when it's sending
you those images.
And as a result, those images
are going to compete with your
bandwidth for the important
resources.
So the browser is doing
you a favor.
Now, if you have a way of
coordinating all these things.
And you have a way of saying
this is higher priority.
For instance, give me my HTML
before you bother to send me
the images.
Give me the JavaScript before
you bother to send me the
images, et cetera.
Then the browser doesn't have
to do this heuristic.
Instead, it can send all the
requests to the server.
And the server can keep filling
up the pipe whenever
it's empty with the most
important thing that it can
find to fill it up with.
SPDY also those interleaving.
Now what this means is that if I
start downloading a video of
my daughter and my boss calls me
up and tells me one of the
servers isn't working, I can
open up a new tab in my web
browser to the same thing and
start looking at the site.
And the server will be smart
enough to pause that
download for me.
And it'll pause it only so long
as it has more important
things to send.
So interleaving means
interruption.
We can interrupt any of the
streams at any point in time
if we have something more
important to say.
And it also means that we can
say things in parallel.
Now what this means,
effectively, is that if your
server has decided to think
for a long time about
something, it's not going to
slow down all the things it
doesn't have to think
about for.
And this ends up being a very
interesting problem for HTTP
called head of line blocking,
probably familiar with it.
We don't suffer from that with
SPDY because of interleaving.
All right, ServerPush.
Now we're just beginning to
play around with this.
And, frankly, I'm really excited
about ServerPush.
ServerPush gives us much better
control over every
aspect of our transaction.
And in particular, unlike inline
which allows us about
the same latency win on the
first request, it allows us to
put stuff in the
browser cache.
It's referred to by its name.
That means on the next page
load, and I hope that you guys
are planning to have the
customer come back to the page
so this should matter.
Is there anyone here that
doesn't hope that the
customers come back
to the page?
Sometimes silence is golden.
So on the second page load, or
subsequent, having these
things in the cache can
be a great benefit.
Don't know about you, what
do you guys think?
Is inlining annoying?
Well I think it is.
So one of the reasons it's
annoying, is despite the fact
it shaves off an RTT,
it's really,
really easy to get wrong.
If I accidentally inline an
image, for instance, before
that critical JavaScript,
I've just ruined my user
experience.
And what works today for
inlining my page doesn't work
tomorrow necessarily.
Because one of the resources may
be written by a different
developer than the other one.
And unless we have some
mechanism that allows us to
redo the order in which we're
inlining every time we've
changed one of the resources
we may be getting it wrong.
And that is fairly often,
unfortunately.
And as I mentioned, beginning
to make its way into
implementations.
And, again, you'll see that
in the demo soon.
I've heard people arguing
against ServerPush.
And I think that they need
to think about it
a little bit more.
The way I think about ServerPush
is that ServerPush
is much better inlining.
It's inlining that
is forgiving.
It's inlining that, when you
make a mistake, and you
include an unimportant resource
because of the
interleaving, the
prioritization, I mentioned
before, it allows the server to
help fix the error for you
without you even really
thinking about it.
And without it impacting
the user much.
So let's say I said,
you know what?
Let's push this image.
And, unfortunately, I forgot
that the CSS is mentioned
after this for some reason.
I just got it wrong.
As soon as the server sees that
there's a request for the
CSS, it will stop filling up
the pipe with that image.
It will send the CSS.
The idea is that we're always
going to send the most
important information
as soon as we can.
So if I get it wrong, server
will make most
of it go away, hopefully.
It's not magic, though.
SPDY uses one connection.
This is actually enabling.
Because this allows us to
do all this beautiful
prioritization.
This allows us to do the
ServerPush because we don't
have this untenable coordination
problem.
For large services, when you
make six connections per
domain, it's very unlikely that
those six connections end
up going to the same host.
Inevitably, most of them
are going to go
to different hosts.
As a result, if you want to
coordinate what's happening
for that user session, you're
going to have to coordinate
the machines that are all
terminating those requests.
That ends up being really
difficult with many
connections.
Now, having one connection
offers other benefits.
It reduces buffer bloat.
And if you're not familiar
with buffer bloat, buffer
bloat is basically the idea
that, because TCP is designed
to fill up every buffer in
between you and the way you're
going, if there's more space
in a buffer it's
going to use it.
And because it's using it, it's
going to increase the
latency, or the apparent latency
over that link as time
progresses.
And I don't know if any of you
have a large buffer on a cable
modem, or have had that
experience in the past.
It gets very painful when
you're doing VOIP.
And the delay with the person
you're conversing with
increases as you've been
talking to them.
I think it's really painful.
I don't like it.
So SPDY, it's helpful.
It doesn't make so
many connections.
As a result, it's less likely
to fill up more buffers.
It will fill up only as much
as it absolutely needs to.
If you're a server guy, it's
nice, the idea that this thing
might use less server
resources.
Now, there's a kind of
trade off in SPDY.
Because we do the header
compression,
we have a Gzip context.
So you're going to be Gzipping
the headers, only the headers
hopefully, on the response.
So you're going to be spending
a little bit more CPU there.
Now we're looking in the
future to change that.
We're looking to make
that faster,
hopefully extremely cheap.
But, for today, it does use
a little bit more CPU,
only for that part.
However, if you have a
lot of SSL because
you care about security.
And your users care about
security, which is probably
why you do, then it might
actually make things cheaper,
because you're going to have
to do many fewer SSL
handshakes.
You're going to have to
be many fewer accepts.
You're going to have to manage
fewer file descriptors.
You're kernel is going to have
to do less context switches.
So there are all of these games
that happen not in the
user space of your application,
but in the system
part of your host.
Another thing it allows you to
do, it allows you to better
measure TCP properties
on your connection.
So one of those, and perhaps the
most important one, is the
congestion window.
The congestion window parameter
for TCP basically
says how many bytes in flight
you're allowed to have at any
point in time.
This ends up being important,
of course, because this is a
form of rate control.
And the way TCP works is that
it discovers this parameter
over the course of
the connection.
And it starts out relatively
small.
For most implementations today,
it's going to start out
around two packets worth.
I don't know about you, but MMS,
let's call it 1,500 just
to make it easy.
That's 3k.
Most request don't fit in 3k,
let alone the responses.
So basically that means that
we're going to have to take
some round trips in order to
open this window up, in order
to be able to actually send all
the request so that then
we can get the responses.
So if we can do something to
speed up that part, then we
have increased the chance that
we have a bigger pipe earlier.
So because, with SPDY, we have
the one connection it gets a
better estimation of what this
is, because speedy allows you
to have the client cache that
setting and tell the server
what it was when it comes
back in the future.
We can open up the pipes
to where it was before.
Not unfairly, right?
We're not doing this
arbitrarily.
We're doing this based on what
the internet said-- or what we
measured of the congestion
over the path for that
particular connection
at that time.
I think that's really cool
because it means that I'm not
limited to sending 3k of
requests for that first thing.
I can send however much the
Seawind eventually got to.
As a result of all this, in
case we are writing load
balancers, for instance,
we use fewer packets.
We use fewer packet, of course,
because we are doing
compression.
And we use fewer packets because
we are using one
connection.
And, as a result of doing
one connection, we
have more full packets.
So we are not forced to fragment
the packets because
they're going to
the same place.
SPDY doesn't require rewriting
your site.
You do not have to
change the URLs.
They remain HTTPS and HTTP.
Those schemes, I'm afraid, are
likely to be here for a very
long time, regardless of what
is spoken underneath.
And the way it works is that
when a connection is made, in
particular an SSL connection,
if your browser speaks SPDY,
it will advertise to the server
in an extension called
Next Protocol Negotiation, I
speak SPDY2 SPDY3, HTTPS, web
sockets, whatever
else it speaks.
And the server can then
respond saying, I have
selected SPDY2.
And, as a result, we get a
zero additional latency
handshake that allows
us to negotiate
whatever protocol we want.
Now, this isn't SPDY specific.
This just a fall out of the work
that was done in order to
enable SPDY.
But it's nice because it gives
us a path forward.
It gives us a path on
a port that allows
us to do new things.
And to stop this ossification
that seemed to be
happening on the web.
We want a web that's continually
fresh, that
renews, all the way down to
its roots, if we can.
So all of this prioritization,
all of the multiplexing, we
figure most of this can
help your site.
But there's that ServerPush
thing.
And ServerPush might take
a little more effort.
SPDY isn't magic.
I've just describe what it is.
Hopefully, you're already
thinking about scenarios where
it may not work for you.
But, in any case,
here they are.
SPDY isn't going to work for
you very well if you have a
whole lot of third
party domains.
And what I mean by third party
domains, is domains that you
do not control the
servers, you do
not control the content.
The more connections you have,
the less likely multiplexing,
and prioritization, and all
this fancy stuff, is
likely to help you.
The more cold starts connections
you have, the less
likely SPDY is to help you.
And I'll point out, when you
have a lot of cold start
connections, it generally means
you don't have a lot of
ongoing engagement
with your users.
So I'm hoping that I've guessed
right, and that you
guys want more engagement
with the user.
And you want that user to be
sticky to your site for as
long as possible.
So the protocol is designed
to help when that happens.
Oh, of course, and if you've
optimized your site so much
that you don't actually have
to use a lot of requests it
may not help you.
It can.
But it may not.
All right so just
to go over it.
HTTP has a bunch
of limitations.
It's not secure.
It doesn't compress, all that
redundancy in the headers.
It doesn't do multiplexing.
It's only half-duplex.
It doesn't do prioritization.
So if you get the order of
requests wrong, well, it's not
going to help you.
No ServerPush, no interleaving,
and of course,
because you have to do all that
domain charting, which I
find annoying, it requires you
to do more DNS lookups.
And, of course, it requires you
to make more connections.
All right, so, aren't browsers
getting smarter?
Yeah, they're getting smarter.
But they're still going
to be worse than
what we do with SPDY.
So why do I say that?
I say that because each
connection that
you make has a cost.
And if we think back to the
beginning, we're using 12
different domains on average.
We're using 84 different
requests.
That's going to require a fair
number of connections.
And each one of these
connections, requires a DNS
resolution.
And looking at data, for a large
percentage of people
that's more than 100
milliseconds right there, just
the DNS request.
It requires a new TCP
connection, which requires a
three way handshake.
You get the SIN, SINAC, AC.
That's another RTT.
If you're using HTTPS, and it
seems like we're going towards
that more and more, than
you're going to
have another few RTTS.
And, of course, these
connections aren't free.
The resources for them don't
show up out of thin air.
We have to pay for the servers
that are making these
connections.
So we want to limit
them if we can.
And, of course, something that
everybody forgets about,
including me, which is why we
have these slides, every
connection you make takes
up space in an address
translation table
on a NAT box.
And these NAT boxes get really
funny when you start
overflowing these tables.
And what ends up happening--
this is super annoying
by the way--
what ends up happening is that
it doesn't bother to send you
any packets anymore.
And it doesn't bother to forward
the packets anymore.
That means it doesn't even
close the connection.
That means that you're
now making requests
into a black hole.
You've put your connection
to dev null.
It's gone.
So we have to be kind of careful
to not overflow these
things if we can.
SPDY and help a lot there.
We're talking about a factor
of, hopefully, an order of
magnitude decrease
in the number of
connections we use today.
And if we continue to use SPDY
for other protocols, if we
continue to use SPDY for HTTP,
HTTPS, hopefully something
like web sockets, we're
going to have less
problems in this area.
So what can you do?
If you're a system administrator
and this is a
complex issue, try and optimize
your searching.
And I'll point out that every
single one of the things I'm
going to talk about here, with
the exception of some DNS
stuff, is going to be helpful
for you regardless of whether
or not you're optimizing
for SPDY.
When you're optimizing for SPDY,
you end up optimizing
for HTTPS as well.
So ask your cert provider hard
questions, like how many
browsers that are out there
right now have you as a
trusted cert provider?
The more browsers that are
there, the fewer certs in your
cert you have to send.
Now, typically I think we see a
cert chain of around three,
which means that we need three
certs to get to most of them.
But we can get more
cute than that.
If we're doing SPDY, we see
SPDY has been negotiated.
We know it's either Firefox
13 or a Chrome browser.
Both of those are
fairly modern.
Thus, we don't have to send
all of that data.
We don't have to send that
third one definitely.
We may only have to
send one cert.
And as a result, our handshake
gets smaller.
The amount of bandwidth
we spend is smaller.
And this happens whether or
not we're using SPDY.
If you see the NPN is there,
even if you don't want to do
SPDY you can change which
SSL certs you send.
So because we deployed SPDY, we
might speed up HTTPS, ah,
competition, oh well.
You can change your
TCP settings.
If you have a modern Linux
kernel on your server this may
be done for you already.
The trunk for Linux, and some
other versions, I don't recall
exactly which unfortunately,
already have an initial
congestion window of 10.
But here's the magic
command to set it.
It's IP route change default,
via whatever is your gateway,
[? IPCwind ?]
10.
And that magic invocation will
set it to 10, which according
to Google research seems
to be about right.
You also want to turn off this
TCP-slow-start-after-idle,
which, despite the
way it sounds--
I mean, it sounds like it
should be nice, right?
I mean idle, if my connection
has not been doing anything
for 60 seconds, yeah let's
close it down.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
always end up that way.
The connection can be idle for
one packet worth sometimes.
And it can cut the Seawind
down all the
way back to the beginning.
Ow, we probably need to
rethink this thing.
But for now you can just turn
it off using that command.
DNS, this one gets
complicated.
SPDY can share a connection
on multiple domains.
But it requires two
things to happen.
It requires that the resolution
for the host that
you're going to go to next
overlaps with the IP of the
connection that you're connected
to right now.
And that the cert matches.
Got it?
Good.
So, profit, fewer connections
means less latency, means less
server utilization--
well, rather, more server
utilization, less CPU.
And it's basically
a good thing.
Don't shard host names when
you're using speedy.
You don't have to.
You already have a lot
of parallelism.
SPDY has a default parallelism
of 100.
And it seems like the browsers
jack that up as
soon as they connect.
I think Chrome is announcing
10,000 now for the next
version that's coming out.
So you don't have to shard
your host names.
Doing so may cause at least a
DNS look up, and potentially
another connection.
You don't need to do it.
Try and use ServerPush instead
of inlining in the future when
support for it becomes a
little bit more mature.
And support for this is
maturing very quickly.
I know, for instance, that Jetty
has an implementation
that does some things that don't
require any action on
your behalf at all.
And, in fact, it learns from
the referrer what resources
end up being associated
with stuff.
We're hoping that we can make
this even better as time goes
on and make this even
more hands free.
Get a wild card cert.
You should do this because
it's cheaper
in the first place.
And I mean that because if you
get one cert, it's most of the
time cheaper than getting five
certs, six certs, however many
subdomains you have.
It's also good because it
allows SPDY to share the
connections.
Remember, SPDY will share
a connection when the IP
overlaps with whatever
connection it already has and
when the cert matches.
A wild card cert matches
more than one domain.
That's great.
Just to let you know on
standards, hopefully, because
of us, HTTP2.0 has
been kicked off.
And we have proposed
SPDY as one of the
inputs to this standard.
So we're hoping that we end up
with an HTTP2.0 that gives us
many of the things that
SPDY gives us today.
Hopefully all of them.
So the future, we don't think
we're done with SPDY.
I believe that we'll be done,
at least at the application
layer, when there is no dead air
on that connection at all.
And at the end of that sending
of data, the page has been
delivered completely
to the user.
We're not there yet.
We use multiple domains.
We use multiple domains that
have different certs.
have different certs that end
up going to the same server.
So we can do better.
We can push the SSL certs.
We can also push the
DNS information.
And pushing the DNS information
gets really
interesting for other reasons.
If you have a CDN, for instance,
you can do much
better geolocation.
You can change where the user
is making that connection to
something that's significantly
closer to your resources.
And thus you can decrease both
the amount of work that's done
by you, but also you can
decrease the latency, which
is, of course, why we're
talking about this.
So as I mentioned before, we've
got Chrome supporting.
And we have Firefox
supporting it.
And I'll point out that's
a lot of users.
Now on the server side, of
course Google Sites use it.
Any App Engine sites
using HTTPS use it.
So if you have an App Engine
app that uses HTTPS stuff,
you're already using it.
You don't even realize it.
Twitter uses it.
Akamai has announced that they
are going to support it very
soon, as a technology preview
starting very soon.
And next quarter they say that
they're going to have it out
in production for everyone.
Cotendo, EngineX, F5, Jetty,
Mod SPDY, node SPDY,
Momentum, et cetera.
So let's get to some
more good stuff.
So here we have a page
we want to optimize.
And you'll see, as I'm moving
the cursor around, that this
seems to be made up of a
whole bunch of tiles.
You're right.
It is.
It's 640 tiles.
Now hopefully this is going to
be more resources than your
average webpage today.
And obviously this is
going a little far.
But I'm here to make a point.
So here we go.
I have conditioned my local
host to act kind of like a
mobile connection that
we would get today.
It's a megabit 200
millisecond RTT.
Let's see how this loads.
This is eight way
domain charted.
Not too speedy.
All right, let's try it again.
This time we're just
going use SPDY.
We didn't do anything fancy.
We're not doing any
ServerPush.
I didn't modify the
site in any way.
Let's see what it looks like.
It seems to be going better.
You'll notice that
it got faster as
it loaded more resources.
That's that opening up of the
TCP connection that I was
talking about.
If I load this again it's
going to end up faster.
But I have more interesting
things to show you.
So I'm not going to do that.
So I told you about
ServerPush.
So I imagine many of you have
imagined you might be
something like this.
You might decide, you know what,
I'm just going to tell
it it should push all
those resources.
If you look at timing, by the
way, that was a lot faster.
This is my favorite.
You know what?
I don't really care about
how quickly the
full site comes there.
I only really care about the
above the fold time.
I care about the amount of time
it takes before the site
becomes useful to the user,
before it becomes attractive
for the user to use.
So why don't I do this?
Why don't I push the resources
that are important first.
Let me do that again.
I'll make a note.
Personally, I think
SPDY is important.
You know, I kind of
helped invent it.
So there you go.
And that's all I have.
I'll take questions
for two minutes.
And I'll let somebody
else fill the time.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERTO PEON: So one of the
things that's great about
SPDY, is that you're guaranteed
that if anybody
supports it.
And actually, you can just
look at it from the NPN
perspective.
If anybody supports NPN, you
know they're a modern browser.
You know that they do the TLS
thing that announces the name
as part of the TLS handshake.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERTO PEON: You
don't have to.
So if you don't have NPN in the
SSL extension it just ends
up being HTTPS.
So it's fully backwards
compatible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERTO PEON: Right,
any other questions
AUDIENCE: Why not
a SETP or a TCP?
ROBERTO PEON: We
looked at that.
SETP has some problems for
actual deployment.
In particular, it deals very
poorly with NAT boxes.
A lot of the things that we
designed for with SPDY were
inspired by things like
SETP and [? Beep ?].
AUDIENCE: But it gives you
multi-homing and high
availability, which I think is
not there in SPDY right now.
ROBERTO PEON: That's correct.
It doesn't give us multi-path.
Now, in reality, I haven't
actually seen SETP give us
multi-path, either, though.
I would really like for it to.
It's just very difficult
to deploy for real.
And in this case we're trying
to deliver something that we
can deliver very widely.
AUDIENCE: Specifically about the
congestion window caching.
I know you guys online have
talked about the potential
issues around forging that and
issues with the connection
changing between requests.
But I guess what hasn't been
clear to me, is the connection
window sizing a requirement?
If a browser sends it are you
required to start with the
number they want?
ROBERTO PEON: You are
not required.
It is a hint.
AUDIENCE: How does SPDY handle
termination of SSL at the load
balancer if you have a hardware
load balancer that's
passing to the back end?
ROBERTO PEON: If you have a
hardware load balancer, and it
doesn't support SPDY, you're not
going to be speaking SPDY.
So the way it's going to be
handled is hopefully,
eventually, many of
these vendors will
be supporting SPDY.
And having gone around and
talked to a number of them, I
can't promise anything.
I'm not the vendors.
But it seems like there's
interest.
AUDIENCE: How is the priority
defined for these?
ROBERTO PEON: There's a bit
field that's in there.
And basically the lower the
number in that bit field the
higher the priority.
Probably should have done it the
other way around because
it gets confusing.
But that's how it is.
I know there are at least 16
different levels of priority.
We might decide to change that
at any point in the future.
But if we did it would
probably just
be to increase it.
All right, one last question
and then I'll yield.
AUDIENCE: The other thing would
be is there any point to
doing push versus inlining.
Like, normally for HTTP you do
inlining so that you don't get
the round trips.
Is there any point to push with
SPDY since it's already
doing that RTT compression?
ROBERTO PEON: There is.
Hopefully, you're optimizing
your site for the whole
experience and not just
the first page load.
So if all you're doing is the
first page load, you're right.
So long as you get the inlining
right, which is
another problem, so long as you
get it right, it's going
to be basically the same
as ServerPush.
If you get it wrong, it's not.
If you have resources that could
have been cached, but
aren't because data URLs don't
allow you to do anything like
that, then ServerPush is going
to end up better the second
page load even when they
come to it anew.
And it's going to be better on
any portion of the session
after that.
Last question?
AUDIENCE: For a scenario where
you have browsers which you
can't really change, at least
not in a short amount of time
like embedded systems, would a
scenario like a client side
proxy of HTTP to SPDY actually
be worth it?
ROBERTO PEON: Do you mean a
proxy from SPDY to HTTP?
So SPDY on the client side?
AUDIENCE: The other way
around actually.
The browser does HTTP requests,
but they get out of
the embedded equipment
in SPDY.
ROBERTO PEON: Both can work.
SPDY is going to be most
advantageous when it's used
over the higher RTT link.
So if you're speaking SPDY
directly to your server,
because there's a load balancer
in front of it that's
speaking SPDY to your server,
the benefits, in terms of
latency, aren't going
to be there.
But if that proxy is close to
the client, then you will see
benefit hopefully.
Thank you very much.